. Ah, guten Tag, liebe Sonne. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast UFO, das kleine Mittelalter-Dorf, das Podcast UFO, ein bisschen nördlich von Nottingham. Und wir haben nichts zu befürchten, die Sonne lächelt uns an und nichts kann uns diesen Tag verderben. Wir haben hier schon seit hundertmorgenden und abenden keinen Drachen mehr gesehen. Und immer wenn wir unsere Augen schliessen, öffnen wir sie am nächsten Tag und so ist es gut. Ohne zu wissen, was wie warum. Wir sind im Mittelalter, wir wissen nichts. Warum müssen wir die Augen zumachen nachts, warum ist es nachts dunkel, das wissen wir nicht, aber das muss uns auch nicht interessieren, denn uns geht's gut hier und uns wird nichts passieren.
Mut und wir haben Gott.
Ja, er ist bei uns, er lächelt uns jeden Morgen von seinem grossen Berg aus an.
Ist das die katholische Lehre?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Wir sind da nicht so.
Es war vor zwei Jahren mal ein Priesterherr, der hat uns das erklärt, aber ich habe ihn nicht gehört, ich war krank.
Ich hatte Mums.
Mums.
Herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr da seid zum Podcast Mittelalter-Ufo, zum Podcast-Karren. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid mit Stefan von Titzingham. Und mit Flo und den Der Schwarze Ritter Will. Dankeschön, vielen, vielen Dank. Und natürlich auch vielen Dank an Marius, der uns mit diesen herrlichen, atmosphärischen Klängen in die Folge begleitet hat. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Gab es mal einen Film, wo dann der Schwarze Ritter Obacht der Gute war? Oh, interessante Idee. Ich glaube, jeder Ninja-Film ist die Idee, oder? Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau. Wie der Ninjas? Ich glaube, ich war ja oft auf dem Kaltenberger Ritter-Turnier, da hat der Schwarze Ritter immer eine große Rolle gespielt und am Ende dann, glaube ich, gab es schon ein paar Mal den Plot. weil gerade so ein Plot in so einer Turnierumgebung ist gar nicht so leicht, aber die haben sich echt immer was ausgedacht. Das war immer ein grösstes Highlight in meiner Kindheit, auch wenn ich da oft mit Charme zurückdenke, weil ab einem gewissen Punkt war ich halt weniger Mittelalter-Fan als Helle-Ringe-Fan. Und das hat aber nicht so ganz gut zusammengepasst auf diesem Mittelalter-Markt, wo alles sehr... Also wurdest du mit deinen spitzen Elbenohren immer ein bisschen bekannten. Genau, mit meinem Elbenohr, mit meinem Stich und ich habe für Gondor geschrieben. Also alles durcheinander. Also du hast... Man wusste es nicht, ist er Zwerg? Der Bart sagt Zwerg, die Ohren sagen Elb, Stich sagt Beutlin. Der Helm sagt Gondor, mit der weissen Hand von Saruman drauf. Ein bisschen konfus und deswegen nicht nur deswegen bin ich da so ein bisschen schlecht aufgefallen, weil die Leute gesagt haben so, ja du bist hier irgendwie in Niederdeutschland, im Teutonenreich irgendwas. Und unvergessen die Sonnenbrille, die du die ganze Zeit trotzdem aufhattest, die Oakley-Sonnenbrille. Klar. Aber ich glaube, da ist mein Fandom abgespalten von Mittelaltertum zu, nee, ich mag Fantasy, nicht Mittelalter.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Lektion, die viele junge Leute lernen müssen, die irgendwann anfangen, dann Heraldik zu lernen und irgendwie so Pest und wie eine Burg funktioniert. Und die sagen, nee, eigentlich interessiert mich mehr dieses Zauberzeug. Wo sind die Drachen, wo sind die Zwerge? Das interessiert mich eigentlich mehr. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch für so echte Hardcore-Mittelalter-Freaks, muss man gerade so im Studiengang oder so immer gucken, wo sind die Fantasy-Leute, die möglichst schnell raus sortieren. Ist nicht die Frage, bist du eher Journalist oder Drehbuchautor oder bist du eher dokumentarisch unterwegs oder kreativ unterwegs? Bist du Taxifahrer oder Rennfahrer? Hm. Ne? Ja. Ähm, ja, wir haben eine pick-up-packvolle Sendung für euch. Bist du Barkeeper oder bist du ... Nee, es ist ein bisschen ... Bist du Magier oder bist du der Magiertrick-Erfinder? Okay. Bist du Barkeeper oder bist du Cocktail-Erfinder? Bist du Pilot oder der, der das Flugzeug gebaut hat? Genau. Okay. Bist du das Pferd? Ich glaube, wir haben genug Beispiele gefunden, um das klar zu verdeutlichen. Es kann aber mehr sein. Gib mir noch ein paar. Gib mir noch ein paar Beispiele mehr. Ja, okay. Das heißt, wie würdest du dafür sorgen, dass in deinem Studiengang keine Fantasy-Leute sind? Wenn du jetzt wirklich so ein Geschichtsprofessor bist, wahrscheinlich genauso wie während der Breaking-Bad-Zeit, wo du merkst, ah, da kommen sie, I'm the one who knocks. Und du denkst dir so, okay, wir machen heute Rettungsreaktionen, es hilft euch gar nichts, sieben Staffeln Breaking Bad gesehen zu haben. Ja, ihr kennt ein paar Elementzeichen aus dem Vorspann und so, aber damit kommt ihr nicht so weit im Chemiestudium. Und die müssen erst mal aussortiert werden mit den ganzen coolen Sprüchen. Ich wäre der Dozent mit dem Girls Watch Out on the Night's Watch Shirt, Game of Thrones Shirt, und wäre eher geneigt, die Leute, die wirklich geschichtliche Hard Facts hören wollen, rauszumobben. Ah, okay, verstehe. Ich wäre eher auf der Quote-unquote falschen Seite. Du würdest den Universitätsbetrieb langsam umkremmeln auf eine reine Fantasy-Schule. Wir denken uns unsere eigene Folklore aus. Und am Ende des Tages steht ... Wobei, ich glaube, da ist man am Ende. Ich glaube, Fantasy hat bislang aus dem Vollen geschöpft und ist jetzt einfach ausgeschöpft. Ich glaube, Fantasy hat jetzt alles, was es gibt. Goblins, Zwerge. Ja. Gargoyles, Zwer Drachen, also diese Fantasy-Welt ist doch jetzt, wenn angenommen, also Richard Wagner hat das dann irgendwann benutzt, dann hat JFK Tolkien das benutzt, und irgendwie hat man sich auf die gleichen Dinge geeinigt. Drachen, Zwerge, Helben, Menschen. Und das ist auch gut so, weil es ist dann oft so, wenn in Fernsehs-Universum so komplett neue Sachen kommen, denkt man sich auch so, zum Beispiel bei DSA, was ich viel spiele, da gibt es dann irgendwann die Hummeria, das sind Hummermenschen. Ja. Und da kommt man nicht umhin, selbst als Charakter in der Welt zu sagen, Hummermenschen? Ja, ja. Wirklich, wir kämpfen jetzt gegen Hummermenschen, also ich meine, okay. Irgendwann kippst halt in Richtung Parodie, weil überleg mal, wenn im Verbotenen Wald bei Harry Potter kam er dann irgendwann im Fangornwald bei Harry Potter, äh, nein, sorry, kam ja irgendwann Firenze, der Minotaurus. Genau.
Halb Mensch, halb Pferd.
Das ist genau die Grenze.
Weiter kann man nicht gehen. Nee, ein kompletter Taurus,
halb Mensch, halb Biber,
großes Nein. Nein, nein, nein.
Da gibt es ein fiktionales Nein, nein.
Unten Mensch oben fährt, nein.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Nein, fährt unten, Mensch oben, ja, aber das ist genau die Grenze. Stell dir mal vor, da wäre ein Hummermensch um die Ecke gekommen, der hat das Franchise ja niemand mehr ernst genommen. Das meine ich, Fantasy hat Grenzen. Total, ja. Und die sind erreicht, die liegen irgendwo zwischen Minotaurus und Hummeria. Und du läufst in der Regel besser, wenn du versuchst, die Klischees zu erfüllen, nicht unbedingt zu brechen. Jeder, der neu einsteigt und ein Abenteuer schreibt, denkt, ich will alle Fantasy-Klischees brechen, bei mir gibt es nicht Orks und Elben, bei mir sind die Elben böse und die Orks gut und das und das und so und das funktioniert nie. Das funktioniert nie. Das ist immer auch ein Race-Shit, also das ist immer eine Race-Thematik auch, ne? Ja. Immer ein bisschen problematisch auch, dass die Orks immer die Bösen sind. Ja, was heißt Böse? Die sind nur missverstanden und einfach die sind ja dann so leicht zu manipulieren von einem dunklen Herrscher und deswegen sind die dann immer... Es ist immer so eins zu eins. Es gibt immer die komplett Bösen und die Guten, für die man ist. Ja. Und die Guten sind meistens wahnsinnig blond. Das ist Fantasies. Ein bisschen überholt, ehrlich gesagt. Sorry. Du, mach deine Fantasy-Revolutionen. Wo ist die nächste Serie, Stefan? Wann kommt die nächste Serie? Wir warten und warten und warten. Ich warte. Das ist halt auch viel Arbeit. Ich refresh halt jeden Tag. IMDb, Eintrag Stefan Tietze, nichts. Das ist halt auch viel Arbeit. Nichts. Da steht immer noch der ganze alte X-Faktor-Kram drin, den ich immer und wieder durchbinge.
Nee, den habe ich da einfach löschen gemacht. Das Ding ist, IMDb geht mir richtig auf die Nerven, weil alles was, also ich glaube, irgendwann stimmt das dann, wenn man bekannt ist, stimmt das irgendwann. Bei mir ist da so viel Unsinn und viele Sachen fehlen oder sind zu viel eingetragen. Es ist irgendwie, weil das stört einen an so einem gewissen Punkt, wenn man halt noch nicht Brad Pitt ist, stört einen das sehr, dass alle einfach das ändern können und so. Und bei How to Sell Drugs, Online Fast, waren ganz lange Autoren drin, die es nicht gibt. Also die es nicht gibt. Einfach Leute haben sich dann da eingetragen und so. Und immer Da denkt man so, ja. Also IMDb hat für mich da keinen Wert. Das ist nicht gibt. Also die es nicht gibt, einfach Leute haben sich dann da eingetragen und so, und immer denkt man so, ja, also IMDb hat für mich da keinen Wert, das ist nicht reliable. Ja, und auch die Gewichtung kann manchmal in die Irre führen, so wenn du dann in einem Film mitgespielt hast, aber halt in 200 Almost Dailys sass, dann sieht dann die IMDb-Seite halt gewichtet aus wie, ja, du, da ist hauptsächlich in Almost Dailys, weil es sind einfach Hunderte, wo Fans das einfach reinschreiben und die tatsächlich wirklichen Perlen gehen. Internet-Movie-Database, nicht Internet-YouTube-Clips-Database, ist auch ein bisschen schwierig. Bei mir sind 90 Folgen gute Arbeit und eine Kredit. Und bei dir ist es halt Auto-Sale-Drugs geht unter in dem ganzen Almost Daily. Aber ist auch sympathischer. Ist viel sympathischer, ehrlich gesagt. Absolut, total. Aber ich bin ja auch viel auf Letterboxd unterwegs, weil ich mag es immer gerne, wenn ich einen Film angeschaut habe, den dann abzuhaken auf Letterboxd. Macht fast mehr Spaß, als den Film anzuschauen. Also oft lohnt sich das Kinoticket schon dafür, dass du bei Letterboxd sagen kannst, habe ich gesehen. Jetzt war ich im Kino The Batman. The Batman. The Batman. Haben wir die Geschichte schon jemals erzählt? Ich weiß nicht, was wir sie jetzt erzählen können. Also es gibt einen Wecker. Es gibt einen Wecker, einen Batman-Wecker. Irgendwo habe ich gesehen, dass es diesen einen Wecker gibt, der spricht. Und zwar weckt er dich morgens mit, Gotham City ist in Not, ruft Batman. Es ist diese sehr spezielle Rhythmik des Satzes, Gotham City ist in Not, ruft Batman. Vor allem Batman einfach falsch ausgesprochen. Naja, englisch ausgesprochen. Batman? Batman. Und wer auch immer diese, ich finde das eine fantastische Vorstellung, dass irgendjemand irgendwo in einem Tonstudio saß und nicht nochmal, wie spricht man denn aus, sondern völlig selbstbewusst gesagt hat, hier ist Batman. Alles klar, ich gehe nach Hause, tschau, macht's gut. Und niemand in dem Turnstil gesagt hat, schön, können wir noch einen anderen Take machen, wo du es richtig aussprichst? Und das ist jetzt halt in diesem Wecker drin, so hard, hardwired, das kriegst du nicht mehr raus. Und dieser Wecker hat eine Rolle bekommen in Gute Arbeit Originals, dem Sketch-Präsidentschaftswahl, wo dieser Wecker Präsident werden will. Genau, da haben wir natürlich die Filet, wir wollten das Satirefilet herausschneiden.
Ja, mit einem ganz feinen Skypell. Und da waren wir ganz fein am Start. Wir haben nämlich diese grandiose, und die ist ein bisschen feinfühlig, feinstofflich, da muss man jetzt ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen abstrakt, Da muss man darüber nachdenken, wir haben nämlich ja, weil Donald Trump auch als Präsidentschaftskandidat am Start war und sehr umstritten war, haben wir überlegt, dann ist da auch ein Batman-Toaster, ein Batman-Wecker am Start und ein Toaster. Ein Toaster wäre unglaublich. Das ist genau die Fantasy-Grenze. Mit einem Batman-Toaster, mit einem Batman-Toaster, da hätten die Zuschauer gesagt, ein Toaster, das gibt doch gar keinen Sinn. Aber ein Wecker kann sprechen. Da haben wir wirklich schon die anstaltartiges
Satire-Niveau erreicht.
Haben nicht alle verstanden,
viele hochgehobene Augenbrauen.
Aber wir dachten,
um es nochmal zu erklären, alle mit ins Boot zu holen,
wir wollten quasi die Absurdität eines
Donald Trumps überhöhen,
damit das ein Wecker auch am Start.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich.
Wenn der Präsident werden kann, kann auch ein Wecker Präsident. Zum Beispiel, aber jetzt nicht wirklich so scharf. Naja, naja. Also da muss man ja, da schneidet man sich ja die Finger auf an so einem Sketch. Also nicht, dass unsere Meinung, die Meinung des Sketch ist es auch nicht, dass ein Wecker dann die Aufgaben eines Präsidenten erfüllen kann. Nein, nein, das nicht. Nur, wir wollten halt sagen, dass es ähnlich absurd ist. Ja, ja. So, und dann haben wir diesen Batman-Wecker dahingestellt, weil ich irgendwo davon gehört hatte, dass es diesen weirden Wecker gibt. Ich wollte ihn ja nur privat haben für mich in meiner Wohnung. Aber der Wecker, der da stand, war nicht der echte Wecker. Genau, die Ausstattung hat dann aber nicht diesen originalen Wecker bekommen, weshalb dann irgendein Batman-Weckercker hingestellt wurde, ich ins Tonstudio gehen musste und diesen falschen Satz da einsprechen musste, der an Ruder gepitcht wurde und dann draufgeklatscht wurde. Auf den Sketch. Am Ende hört man das und es macht keinen Sinn. Also das Easter Egg ist so verschwurbelt da am Ende drin gelassen. Und hat auch noch falsch gefaked worden, so dass es niemand versteht. Aber es gibt irgendwo da draußen diesen Wecker, solche Sachen sind in der Regel viel wert, so Dinge, die dann irgendwie von Fehldruck oder irgendwie falsch aufgenommen oder falsch ausgesprochen. Falls ihr diesen Wecker habt, schaut mal noch zu Hause im Kinderzimmer, vielleicht hat jemand von euch diesen uralten Batman-Wecker, wo Batman gesagt hat, vielleicht habt ihr deswegen auch eure gesamte Kindheit Batman gesagt und vielleicht ist er heute wahnsinnig filmiert, denn Batman ist natürlich gerade in aller Munde. Batman ist aber auch ein anderer Superheld
einfach, mit so einem wahnsinnig hotten
Butt.
Der sieht einfach zu gut aus in seinem
hautengen Kostüm.
Der kann alle zerquetschen damit. Es ist grossartig.
Ich habe mir The Batman angeschaut im Kino
und
man kann viel über den Film sagen,
aber erstmal wahnsinnig humorlos,
wo ich laut aufgelacht habe und ich glaube ein Gag ist in dem ganzen Film, aber der ist richtig gut, wo Catwoman zu Batman sagt, du hast noch nie davon gehört, lebst du in einer Höhle oder was? Fand ich richtig guter Gag. Batcave, Batman lebt in einer Höhle, was sie nicht wissen kann, aber fantastisch. Way too funny to laugh. Richtig guter Gag. Und ansonsten kein Humoror. Eigentlich ist es ja, ich habe von dir noch nie gehört, ich glaube, ich lebe in einer Höhle. Nee, du lebst unterm Stein. Ich habe noch nie gehört, ich lebe hinter dem Mond. Das hat ja SpongeBob gemacht, wo Patrick Star ja unter einem Stein lebt, weil er so dumm ist. Zum ersten Mal er hat es verstanden. Genial, brillant. Oder er hätte auch hinter dem Mond leben können.
Was ist das? Das Patrick Star hinten am Mond klebt. Also auch hier, Spongebob ist lustiger als der neue Batman-Film. Also nur um das mal ganz klar abzugrenzen. Es ist Spongebob und es ist Batman. Spongebob, ja. Es ist nicht Spongebob und es ist nicht Batman. Ansonsten geht es in dem Film um den Riddler, der immer Rätsel stellt. Und das Lustigste für mich an dem ganzen Film war, wie lächerlich schnell Batman diese Rätsel löst. Dieser Riddler Was hat einen Rücken, aber kann nicht stehen? Mehlwurm. Dammit. Und das denke ich mir nämlich auch immer. Dieser Riddler sitzt da in seinem geheimen Hauptquartier und denkt sich diese Rätsel aus und immer Wasser was hat tausend Gründe, aber nur einen Anlass, Rache. Und dass der Ritter nicht mal sagt, ach komm, Alter, einmal! Hat er so eine Marktforschung, so ein Rätselforschungsteam da sitzen und guckt dann, wie lange die brauchen, weil er kann es ja nicht zu hart machen für Batman. Ne, das stimmt. Es muss ja lösbar sein, und der ist ja dann auch so Psychopath und will dann auch irgendwie damit in seinen Opfern spielen und so alles wunderbar. Aber einfach die Tatsache, und vor allem stehen immer mindestens vier Leute zusammen und hören sich dieses Rätsel an und alle denken nach und Batman halt einfach instant. Und ich hätte eine Szene eingebaut, wo die anderen drei sagen, Alter, gib uns doch mal zehn Sekunden oder so. Er hat das Rätsel noch nicht mal beendet. Und irgendwann beendet Riddle auch die Rätsel nicht. wie man dann sagt so, was ist weiss und hat vier Milch. Taschentuch. Ja, ja, richtig.
Das ist einfach so. Es ist grossartig. Vor allem diese ganzen Rätsel haben in der Regel keinen Sinn, weil Batman sie sofort löst. Man könnte es einfach weglassen. Das ist ein merkwürdiger Film, finde ich. Es gibt verschiedene Meinungen darüber. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, weil Rätsel auch einfach das Nervigste der Welt sind. Das ist das Nervigste der Welt, weil es ist halt so ein bisschen, woran denke ich gerade mässig, weil es gibt auf diese dumme Art von Rätsel keine richtige Antwort. Bei Hobbit auch immer so. Ja, ja, was hat einen Fuß, aber kann nicht gehen? Ja, ein Berg. Ja, fuck. Ja, so ... Scheiße, die Marktforschungsgruppe ist inzwischen zu schlecht, die ich da hab. Die sagten immer, dass die Räsel stark genug sind für Batman. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Film. Aber auch gut durchgezogen, dass der oft schwarz im Gesicht ist, wenn er seine Maske abgezogen hat, Batman, weil er hat ja um die Augen gemacht, so schwarzes Make-up, was oft verschwindet, wenn er seine Maske abnimmt, dieses Mal nicht. Diesmal sieht er halt einfach traurig aus, weil er halt so wie so verweintes Make-up immer hat. Ich meine, Robert Pattinson sieht da eh immer traurig aus, der ist einfach schlecht drauf, einfach eine schlechte Woche. Und ich mir denke, der Batman löst hundert Rätsel jeden Monat, bei dem Fall war er halt gleich mal schlecht drauf. Du kannst auch schlecht drauf sein, also super. Und als Film musst du ja nicht, du musst ja zu den Parts springen, die spannend sind zu erzählen. Diese doofen Ereignisse davor und dann dieses doofe Steuerproblem bei Wayne Enterprise. Und dieses, ja was meinen Sie denn, ist Lieferung zwischen 12 und 16 Uhr, ich habe um 14 Uhr einen Termin, also kann ich jetzt, soll ich jetzt warten bis 14 Uhr und dann rufe ich sie zurück, wenn die Lieferung noch nicht kam? Das schneidet man dann dann weg als Film.
Genau, und du weißt gar nicht, warum er so traurig ist.
Das dann bei Wayne Enterprise davor, diese blöde Finanzuntersuchung, da war PwC halt lange oder KPMG.
Und Batman in der Buchhaltung, die 2018er Unterlagen, die haben wir doch schon.
Nein, aber das ist ja viertes Quartal.
Das ist ja viertes Quartal 2018.
Wieso reden Sie so, Mr. Wayne? Ach so, ach so, fuck, sorry. Also, 16 Unterlagen hatte ich Ihnen doch schon letztes Jahr geschickt. In meinem Kopf läuft immer hinter jemandem so einem NDA rum, der dann immer Leuten das geben muss, wenn er sich versprochen hat. Genau, sie wissen nicht, dass er Bruce ist. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich habe schon mal unterschrieben, dass sie nicht Batman sind. vor allem, ich fände ja einen Film gut,
wo es nur darum geht, dass sie nicht Batman sind. Vor allem, ich fände ja
einen Film gut, wo es nur darum geht,
dass Batman versucht, weil Batman
versucht ja immer, seine Identität zu schützen. Genau.
Er ist Bruce Wayne, niemand darf es wissen. Ja.
Und ich fände einen Film gut, wo er eigentlich nur versucht,
den Verdacht auf jemand anderen zu lenken.
Dass der Batman ist und Bruce Wayne
immer so versucht so, vielleicht ist der
der Batman, oder? Und dann
wirft er so das Kostüm so durchs Fenster durch und dann sagt er, Moment mal, da ist es doch und er so, was, ich bin ja nicht Batman und dann ist er irgendwie plötzlich Batman und so im Sinne von ihm ablenken und so, das ist der Held, den wir brauchen. Gibt so ein bisschen in Dark Knight. Ist ein bisschen Dark Knight. Naja, aber da sagt ja eigentlich Harvey Dent auf eigene Faust, dass er Batman ist, im Sinne von, um das auf sich zu nehmen. Ja, genau. Er wird ja nicht von Batman gezogen. Vorher sagt er aber, dass Harvey Dent ja der eigentliche Held ist. Damit meint er aber nicht, dass er sagt, dass er Batman ist. Gotham braucht ein Held ohne Maske. Always. Krieg mich jedes Mal. Jedes Mal. Gotham braucht ein Held ohne Maske. Weil er sich nicht versteckt hat. Ja, weil er sich nie geschenkt hat in der Maske. Oh Mann, Harvey! Ja, Harvey, Mann! Mann, ey! Was war am Ende los? Mann, er hat, schade, dass du Two-Face gewonnen hast. Ja, ist scheiße. Scheiße, er war der Held, den Gott im Braum. Ja, und am Ende ein fucking Two-Face. Und, also, könnt ihr mal leise sein, wenn ich will den Film sehen? Ja, oh, ne, er hat eigentlich ausredzt. Und am Ende, grundsätzlich,, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,metaphern liebt, dann ist Batman sowas von euer Film. Ja. Oh, ich bin richtig elektrisiert. Oh, richtig toll. Aber schön auch mal wieder im Kino zu sein, ich war ja direkt im Anschluss an die Folge im Kino und deswegen mein Tipp, Originalfassung vormittags. Nein, der Zwischenlassen wagen acht Stunden. Ja, das kann sein. Vormittags ins Kino gehen, da sind wenig Vollidioten dabei, Originalfassung gehen, da sind keine Kinder dabei. Falls es euch wie mir so wichtig ist, dass niemand redet während des Films, Vormittags, Originalfassung geht einigermaßen. Super, finde ich ganz toll. Und wenn ihr keinen Job habt und wie Florentin einfach den ganzen Tag nur rumhängt und eh nicht wisst, was ihr mit am Tag anfangen soll, dann könnt ihr in die Vormittagsvorstellung gehen. Nur ich habe einiges auf dem Schreibtisch gerade. Ich weiß. Ich habe ein Riesenproblem nämlich momentan, und zwar, ich bin in einem Brezeldilemma gefangen. Ein Brezeldilemma. Es ist eine absolute Katastrophe. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber irgendwie verbrenne ich immer die Läden, in denen ich gerne einkaufe. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber alle werden Dilemma da haben mit Essen zu tun. Ja, es kann sein, dass das ein großer Fokus meines Lebens ist, aber der lecker Mate-Mann, ich kann nicht mehr hingehen mehr hingehen, geht nicht mehr. Und jetzt ist gerade ein weiterer Laden dabei, sich zu verbrennen, der Brezelladen, Kölner Hauptbahnhof. Kölner Hauptbahnhof Brezelladen. Und zwar ist es immer so, ich feiere immer nach Hamburg und dann gehe ich davor zum Hauptbahnhof, Brezelladen, hol mir zwei Brezeln. Was definiere Brezelladen, Laugenladen? Es ist ein Gebäckladen. Ich weiß genau, was du mein meinst. Die haben eigentlich nur sich auf Laugen... Ist das ein Bäcker? Ja, es sind aber hauptsächlich Laugen-Croissants. Und es fängt mit D an. Nein. Oh, es fängt mit L an. Mit D an. Äh? Äh, äh. Und die haben einen grossen Topf Lauge im Keller. Was dafür spricht, wie viele laugenbasierte Bäcker es gibt im Klau-Panon. Lauge ist etwas Besseres, es gibt. Da hauen die alles rein. Die haben dann auch diese Laugen-Croissants und alles und alles wird weggelaugt, einfach egal, was es gibt. Und erst mal schon, also ich gehe da hin und will zwei Brezeln haben. Ich bin auch bayerischstämmig bereit, dazu Brezeln zu sagen. Kein Problem. Und na, lass uns das jetzt bitte rausschneiden, weil sonst, das ist jetzt zu viel, das ist zu viel. Aber habe ich recht, ich kann sonst nicht... Das ist zu viel, warte, ich schneide mir das auf, ich piep das raus. Ja, ja, du kannst es rauspiepen. Nee, weil das ist, das ist... Nee, weil aber ich konnte mich gerade nicht konzentrieren mehr, weil ich auch wissen wollte, welcher es ist. Flotin, sag mir kurz, was es ist. Ja, okay. Und also, erst mal das Problem, weil ich mag kein Kleingeld dabei haben. Deswegen nehme ich immer, ich habe einen riesigen Kleingeld-Eimer bei mir zu Hause, nehme ich den passenden Cent-Betrag aus diesem Eimer raus, trage ihn zwischen meinen beiden Hummerfingern von meiner Wohnung zum Hauptbahnhof, lege ihn auf dieses kleine Münzbrett und sag zwei Euro, zwei Brezel. Und sag's gut, einstudiert und geübt, zwei Brezel bitte. Ich hätte gerne zwei, zwei Laugenbrezeln, sag mal so. Weil ich bin nämlich der, ich sage, was auf dem Preisschild steht. Immer, egal was da steht. Und ich kenne da kein Pardon. Wenn da steht Laugenbrezel, sag ich Laugenbrezel, sag ich nicht Brezel, ich sage, was da steht.
Ich will unmissverständlich mich ausdrücken.
Erstes Problem, in das ich immer reinrenne, drei Brezeln kosten genauso viel wie zwei Brezeln.
Ich will aber nur zwei Brezeln.
So, also wird schon mal jedes ...
Wir halten hier kurz an.
Angehalten.
Die Story, der Storyzug hält hier an. Kurz. Ausstieg in Fahrtrichtung Fragezeichen. Das Gleis ist belegt im vorderen Streckenabstieg. Wir halten hier erstmal kurz an, bis der Anschluss-Story-Zug dann gleich weiterfährt in Richtung Pointe. So, wir halten hier kurz an. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da ankommen oder ob es Schienersatzverkehr gibt. Oder ob wir eher raussteigen. Oder ob wir in Osnabrück übernachten müssen in einem Hotel. Wir steigen hier kurz in Hamm um. Also, die Frage ist nämlich, was, du bezahlst den Betrag. Für den gibt es erstmal, was ist das? Du kriegst drei eigentlich dafür, du willst aber nur zwei. Kauft den dritten und verschenkt den. Nein, doch, Ich bin Fressnapf. Ich stopfe alles in mich rein, was ich in der Reichweite habe. Kann ich mit sehr guter Läden. Ich werde niemals drei kaufen und dann einen wegwerfen oder jemandem schenken oder irgendwas. Aber wie perfide ist denn das? Ja, es ist perfide. Mach das doch nur dann zehn Cent teurer oder sowas. So, und das heißt. Stellen wir wieder ein? Das ist Akt eins. Fahren wir wieder los? Ja, wir fahren los, langsam. Richtung Akt 2 jetzt. Akt 1 war über Wochen sage ich zwei Brezeln bitte, möchten Sie nicht drei? Nein, ich will zwei. Das waren erstmal über Wochen hinweg, wo ich schon mal den Status eines Vollidioten hatte. Jetzt erinnert mich das gerade an Ocean's Eleven. Nämlich ist genau diese Art Merkwürdigkeit, die einen dich merken lässt. Genau, ja. Ist nämlich genau das, da kommt dieser Weirdo an, der immer, erst mal sehr oft hier ist, zweitens immer den gleichen, den richtigen Centbetrag hat und drittens, man merkt sich dich, weil du immer diese doofe Entscheidung triffst, weil du immer wieder aufs Neue die doofe Entscheidung triffst. Also über diesen ersten Akt habe ich schon einen gewissen Ruf aufgebaut. Pedanter Weirdo, wäre jetzt mein, ja. Akt zwei, die Preiserhöhung. Nein, ja, habe ich kommen sehen. Und zwar leg ich ein Euro hin, zwei Euro hin und sie sagt, zwei Euro zwanzig bitte. Und ich habe ja immer exakt den passenden Centbetrag dabei. Katastrophe. Also sage ich, da muss ich schnell Geld abheben. Also nehme ich meinen Kleingeldstapel. Ehrlich gesagt, Akt 1 lässt mich glauben, dass Sie nicht die Preise erhöht haben wegen Inflation oder weil es gerade nicht so gut läuft, sondern um die eins auszuwischen. Also nehme ich meinen Kleingeldstapel, stopfe ihn hastig in die Tasche, gehe zum Bankautomaten, heb einen 5-Euro-Schein ab, komme zurück, lege den 5-Euro-Schein hin für zwei, zwanzig. Wunderbar, ab jetzt weiß ich, es kostet zwei, zwanzig, zwei Prozent. Ein, merkst du dir. Ab jetzt habe ich immer Kleingeld für zwei, zwanzig dabei, zwei, zwanzig. Freut dich ein bisschen, dass dann Kleingeld einmal ein bisschen schneller leerer geht. Absolut, das Zeug muss weg. Das ist Akt zwei. Akt drei, die zweite Preiserhöhung. Innerhalb welcher Zeit?
Innerhalb von zwei Monaten. Das geht nicht. Der Preis steigt auf zwei Euro vierzig. Wir haben die gleiche Szene wieder, der gleiche Vollidiot, der jede Woche kommt und jede Woche nur zwei Brezeln haben will, obwohl er drei haben könnte, mit seinem Kleingeldturm, kommt und legt zwei Euro zwanzig hin und sie sagt zwei Euro vierzig. Und ich wieder, Stecks hasst sich ein und sagt, er muss nicht schnell Geld abheben.
Geht's im Bankautomat, hebt einen fünf Euro Schein ab. Der Bankautomat inzwischen auch so, was passiert hier? Und danach ist alles wieder in Ordnung, weil ich weiß, zwei Euro vierzig, ich bringe zwei Euro vierzig mit. Jetzt kommt mein Tipp für Folge zwei oder den zweiten Teil des Films, die 20 Cent, die Reserve 20 Cent, weil ich hasse auch Kleingeld bei mir rumzutragen und immer wenn ich laufe, schnell laufe oder so über Kopfsteinpflaster mit dem Roller fahre, klingt es so, als hätte ich so einen Cowboy-Kleingeldbeutel dabei. Ja. Will man ja nicht. Das nervt mich daran. Und dass man immer in die Tasche fasst und dann hat man diese dreckigen Münzen.
Ja.
Wenn du jetzt nur ein 20-Cent-Stück in der Tasche hättest, die Reserve 20 Cent. Und zwar, manche Hosen haben nämlich so eine, manche Jeans haben so eine zweite Tasche. Ja, ich trage auch keine Jeans, hast du schon mal gesehen? Hast du mich jemals gesehen? Nicht immer nur den oberen Körper von dir, der untere ist unter dem Tisch immer.
Aber deswegen die Reserve 20 Cent.
Nee, das kann ich nicht.
Ich mag das Gefühl, mein gesamtes Kleingeld auszugeben in einem Akt. Also das alles weg. Ja, aber du rennst halt in Problemchen rein. Ich renne in Problemchen rein, wie wir auch gleich sehen werden, in Akt 4. Nee, jetzt habe ich die Aktstruktur unsablich 20. Der dritten Preiserhöhung. Wir sehen jetzt auf 2,60. Also, aber das innerhalb von kürzester Zeit, das ist jetzt vielleicht vier, fünf Monate dieser Zeitraum, wurde der Preis dreimal erhöht. Und jetzt wird es interessant, weil jetzt kostet das Ganze plötzlich 2,60 Euro. Ich lege 2,40 Euro hin, sie 2,60 Euro und ich so, oh, ich muss Geld abheben, komme mit einem 5-Euro-Schein wieder und sie sagt, ah nee, 2,40 Euro. Sie reduziert den Preis für mich. Nein, an diesem Punkt und jetzt gibt sie mir 2,60 Euro zurück. So, und jetzt ist nämlich das Ding, ab jetzt, ab jetzt nehme ich jede Woche 2,60 Euro mit und sie sagt aber, nee, 2,40 Euro. Ich habe meinen eigenen Preis mittlerweile. Ich schaue auf das Preisschild, da steht ein Euro 30 für die Brezel. Ich zahle aber nur zwei Euro 40 für zwei. Das heißt, und ich nehme das nicht an, ich will nicht meinen eigenen Preis haben. Ich nehme jede Woche zwei Euro 60 mit, sie sagt zwei Euro 40, ich lege das Geld hin, sie gibt mir 20 Cent von diesem Kleingeldstapel zurück. Was ich glaube, was du nicht weisst, die haben ein Zwei-für-eins-zwanzig-Angebot. Nein, haben sie nicht. Ich gucke das wirklich, ich habe da wirklich schon mit Schal vorm Mund, mit Cappy ins Gesicht gezogen. Und dieser Zeitung mit zwei Löchern drin. Schon oft unterwegs. Und jetzt ist es interessant, weil ich glaube, die haben ein schlechtes Gewissen, dass sie den Preis so oft erhöht haben. Und normalerweise kriegt das ja niemand, genau, niemand kriegt das ja mit, dass der Preis erhöht wurde. Nur ich habe das dreimal so offensichtlich mitbekommen und weiß, dass der Preis innerhalb kürzester Zeit erhöht wurde. Und jetzt wird spannend spannend, weil letzte Woche, und jetzt kommt Akt 5, Finaleakt, letzte Woche war ich da wieder, plötzlich steht da ein anderer Verkäufer, ein junger Mann. Und ich gehe da hin und sage, ich hätte gerne zwei Brezel. Du kannst dir denken, was seine Frage ist. Wollen Sie drei, nicht lieber? Nein, ich hätte gerne nur zwei. Er nimmt also zwei raus, sagt, zwei Euro sechzig bitte, kommt von hinten, seine Chefin angerannt, die mir bis jetzt immer die Brezeln verkauft hat, packt ihn am Arm und sagt, nee, das kostet zwei vierzig. Senkt also vor meinen Augen den Preis auf 2,40 Euro, nur für mich, weil es wahrscheinlich in ihrer Welt ich der einzige bin, der diesen Sonderpreis kriegt, weil vor mir die Schmach besteht, dass ich ihr schmutziges Geheimnis kenne. Was wir jetzt machen ist, ich wette erstens hängt ein Bild von dir hinten Backstage, ich weiß nicht, wie man es nennt, Backstage, sorry. Wo alle Verkäufer auf ihren Auftritt warten und in den Textnummern durchgehen. Vielen Dank, dass Sie da waren, schönen Tag noch. Okay, ich packe das jetzt, ich gehe da jetzt raus. Ich wiederhole es nochmal, weil ich glaube, es ist untergegangen, Backstage. Weil es eine, ja, stark, weil es ein Bäcker ist. Stark! So, und ich, also meine Theorie, wir, wir, wir, wir schleusen jetzt Thais ein. Ja. Thais muss sich da jetzt mal bewerben. Genau. Sie studiert wahrscheinlich schon irgendwo in Heidel irgendwo in Heidelberg. Ja, wirklich schon, auch Nobelpreisanwärterin. Nee, nee, nee, nee, das lassen wir mal schön sein. Machen wir mal ein Semester Pause. Du machst mir mal das vernünftige, Freunde. Wir machen mal ein Semester Pause und gehen zum Laugenbecker. Ja. So, und dort geht sie Backstage und sucht erstens sein Bild. Ja. Und ich will alles wissen, was da passiert ist. Wirklich, ehrlich gesagt, wow. Das ist unfassbar, weil ich hatte ja viele Theorien über diese Situation und ab einem gewissen Punkt wollte ich da auch nicht mehr hingehen. Und es gab eine Phase, Akt 4,5 habe ich zu übersprungen, es gab eine Phase, in der ich da nicht war, sondern alle anderen Brezelläden im Bahnhof durchprobiert habe. Leider sind die alle nicht so gut. Okay. Und ich bin wirklich soziophob, ich verzichte auf Lebensqualität, nur damit ich nicht mit unangenehmen Leuten zusammen sein muss, okay, aber die Brezeln sind gut, was soll ich sagen? Was soll ich sagen? Aber die Vorstellung, dass es dieses Montagsmorgens Monday Meeting gibt, wo die sich hinsetzen und sagen, gut, wir haben die Preiserhöhungen einigermaßen reibungslos, wir haben Missionen, keine Ahnung, wie die das nennen, Zipferl, erfolgreich abgeschlossen, irgendein Wort, ja. Jetzt kommt hier nur immer dieser eine Typ, ihr wisst, wen ich meine, Kleeld-Typ. Ich will nur zwei Brezeln. Alle, die bei Zoom zugeschaltet sind und alle, die am Tisch sitzen, machen, entmuten sich auch dafür bei Zoom. Genau, entmuten sich für. Genau, ein Facepalm geht durch den Raum. Der hat mitbekommen, dass wir Mission Zipferl und Mission Gauderbrötchen in kürzester Zeit durchgeführt haben. Wir können ihm nicht sagen, dass wir die Preise ein drittes Mal erhöht haben. Für ihn kosten die Brezel deswegen zwei Euro vierzig. Okay, zwei Euro vierzig für den. Für alle anderen zwei Euro sechzig, für ihn zwei Euro vierzig. Wie ein zwei Euro vierzig. Außerdem tut einem einfach nur leid, wie er dann immer nervös den Stapel in die Hand nimmt und dann zum Geldautomaten da hinten rennt. Und mit einem druckfrischen fünf Euro Schein zurückkommt. Und mit einem glänzenden fünf Euro Schein zurückkommt. Es ist lächerlich, weil ich glaube, ich hasse Sonderbehandlungen. Ich will nicht irgendwie extra Wurst haben, sondern ich will einfach das zahlen, was da steht.
Und deswegen nehme ich auch jedes Mal 2,60 Euro
mit und kriege dann diese dummen, wie du sagst, Reserve
20 Cent mit, die ich dann den ganzen
Tag wie
so ein Moloch mit mir rumtrage,
das auf meinen Schultern ruht.
Ich will ich nicht.
Du hast halt zu tief hinter die
Fassade geschaut. Du hast der Gesellschaft
ein bisschen zu tief in die Augen gekauft.
Ich habe in den Betriebsraum, ich habe in den Maschinenkeller
Vielen Dank. Will ich nicht. Du hast halt zu tief hinter die Fassade geschaut. Du hast der Gesellschaft ein bisschen zu tief in die Augen gekuckt. Ich habe in den Betriebsraum, ich habe in den Maschinenkeller der Finanzwirtschaft geblickt. Du hast Dinge gesehen, die waren nicht für deine Augen bestimmt. Ich bin wirklich der Insider. Ich könnte jetzt als Whistleblower an die Öffentlichkeit gehen und sagen, das ist eine Preispolitik, hinter der kann ich nicht länger stehen. Das ist ein sehr spezieller Laden jetzt am Kölner Bahnhof. Ich Ich weiß auch nicht, wie viele Nachrichten wäre das jetzt hätte für eine gross angelegte Monitor-Reportale zum Beispiel. Naja, Fokus, da kriegst du eine Seite, oder? Was ist denn eine Fokusseite, kriegt man hin? Dreimal die Preise erhöht, aber es ist schon viel auch, ne, 20 Prozent? Es ist wirklich viel, auch in kürzester Zeit, und ich bin immer voll reingerannt und hab denen das wirklich mit einer beißenden Satire-Masse vor Augen gehalten, wie sie ihre Preispolitik hochtreiben und immer erhöhen. Weil, wie gesagt, das kriegt ja normalerweise wirklich niemand mit. Glaubst du, da gab es dann diese eine Mitarbeiterin, die sich so aufgelehnt hat gegen die da oben und so gesagt hat, da ist immer dieser eine Junge, der herkommt und dann immer so nervös seinen Kleingeldstapelel, seinen süßen Kleingeldstapel weglegt und dann seine Jeans-Sparbuchkarte in den Automaten steckt, um den Fünfer zu holen und dann wiederkommt und dann so, ich stelle mir auch dich ganz klein vor in diesem, wie du dann so, du kommst kaum dran oben und kannst diesen Fünfer ablegen und so und der Stapel kippt auch immer um, wenn du wiederholen willst und so, dass sie dann gesagt hat, nein, wir erhöhen die Preise jetzt nicht mehr, die dann gefeuert wurde und die haben es trotzdem durchgesetzt. Absolut, ich glaube schon. Aber das war wirklich, das ist ja so das Ding, du hast so Theorien im Kopf und du denkst dir, stimmt das, habe ich wirklich nicht den Preis für dich, habe ich was übersehen, wie du auch gesagt hast, gibt es ein Sonderangebot. Aber diese Situation mit dem neuen Lehrling hat es mir so klar vor Augen gebracht. Und vor allem jetzt sind wir in der Situation, ich weiss, was los ist, sie weiss, was los ist, sie weiss, dass ich weiss, was los ist. Aber gab es diesen Blick, diesen kurzen Blick, während sie angelaufen kam von hinten? Sie weicht meinen Blick aus. Sie erträgt das nicht. Ich bin wirklich der bohrende Finger in ihrer Wunde, in ihrer Geldgier, in ihrer Brezelgeldgier, dass sie das immer hochtreibt im Preis. Und wahrscheinlich, ich kriege ja sogar nur zwei Brezeln jedes Mal. Ich habe ja sogar auch
diesen Trick durchschaut.
Aber das heißt,
sie hat das irgendwie hinten
Backstage gehört und
kommt dann nach vorne gelaufen.
Aber wie schnell musste das alles funktionieren?
Weil so schnell ist ja schon alles eingetippt
in die Kasse. Der ist das so wichtig,
weil erstmal, es gab ja viele Verwirrungsmomente.
Erstmal, dass ich meinen Kleingeldstapel hingib,
dass sie nur zwei Brezeln will. Wahrscheinlich hat die
Aber Weil so schnell ist ja schon alles eingetippt in die Kasse. Der ist das so wichtig, weil erstmal, es gab ja viele Verwirrungsmomente.
Erstmal, dass ich meinen Kleingeldstapel hingib, dass sie nur zwei Brezeln will.
Wahrscheinlich hat die im Bugstage gehört, nee, ich will nur zwei Brezeln.
Und sie wusste schon, was kommt. Und dieses ...
Rennt los und haut das Geld aus der Tat.
Zwei, vier, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf, fünf kauft und dann so demonstrativ das Geld hinlegt, zwei Euro 60, die Brezeln nimmt und sie mir überreicht und ich mit so einem selbstzufriedenen Grinsen die Frau dann anschau und ich habe gewonnen, ich habe dir die 20 Cent gegeben, die du nicht haben wolltest und dann genüsse ich diese Brezeln für Speise. Können wir nicht Thais da als Mitarbeiterin einfach einschleusen? Weil ich will alles hören, ich will wissen, wie viele Gespräche es dazu gab, wie offen thematisiert wurde.
Auf der einen Seite, es gab vielleicht eben keine Gespräche, weil der Lehrling das ja nicht wusste.
Vielleicht gibt es ab jetzt Gespräche, dass sie sagt, verdammt, das war so knapp, so knapp war ich davor, alles zu verlieren.
Jetzt muss ich eingreifen, neue Situationen herstellen.
Und jetzt gibt es so ein Booklet, was wieder so ein Flyer zu mir.
Achtung, ein Gesicht von mir. Ein Gesicht von dir, ein zwar zweites Gesicht von dir, was jemand hinten so aufgenommen hat. Der Zwei-für-Dreier und einfach so hier der Zwei-Vierziger. Der Zwei-Vierziger. Ich bin der Zwei-Vierziger und so können sie mich dann überall ausmachen. Das ist der Zwei-Vierziger. Finde ich super,inde ich richtig gut. Aber was soll ich jetzt machen? Was an mir ist es, dass sie wiedererkennen? Also reicht es, wenn ich mir eine Kappe aufsetze, einen Hut oder irgendwie Stelzen habe oder irgendwie sowas? Du fragst, was es an dir ist, was sie wiedererkennen lässt? Versuch schon mal, vielleicht mit Karte zu zahlen einmal. Versuch mal einmal mit Karte zu zahlen. Okay. Weil ... Oh, ich könnte jetzt auf verschiedene Arten. Ich bin jetzt wirklich so an so einem Baumoment, wo ich in verschiedene Äste abbiegen kann. Ich frage mich immer, wie aware sind Leute? Weil du gehst natürlich mit so einem Podcast-Mindset durch die Welt. Mambo-Jam-Jumbo durch die Welt und bist dann da natürlich sehr aufmerksam und reflektierst das und bist mal auf der Suche nach der neuesten Story. Du bist Carla Kolumna unterwegs. Die ja vielleicht nicht. Vielleicht überstellst du denn gerade irgendwie so eine Urheilung. Aber deswegen gab es ja diesen entlarvenen Moment letzte Woche mit dem Lehrling. Das war der entlarvene Moment. Bis dahin dachte ich mir, vielleicht verstehe ich nur was nicht oder die Checkings nicht oder irgendwie komisch, aber dieser entlarvene Moment, wo sie extra noch mal, wo er sagt, 2,60 Euro und sie sagt, nein, nein, 2,40 Euro. Reicht mir nicht als Beweis. Und der erst mal völlig verwirrt. Aber die Ältere kanntest du, die Chefin? Ja, ja, bei der bin ich ja immer. Bei der bist du immer. Und habt ihr ein gutes Verhältnis? Nein, ganz eisiges Verhältnis.
Eisig. Weil ich ja ihr Geheimnis
kenne. Das weiß ich ja nicht. Es kann ja immer noch sein, dass das
Schild vorne falsch gedruckt ist, zum Beispiel. Nein, das kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Weil jetzt, danach müsste ich
mich mal hinter dich stellen und
sagen, ich hätte auch gern zwei Brezel. Ja.
Genau, du bist direkt vor mir
und musst dann den empörten Kunden spielen.
Warum für ihn 2,40? Und wir verstecken dich hinter meinem riesigen massigen Körper. Ich stelle mich da vorhin. Vielleicht habe ich so einen Rucksack an. Hast du einen Rucksack an, in dem ich drin bin? Du stehst ganz dicht hinter mir. Ich stelle mich da vorne hin. Sag, ich hätte gern zwei Brezel. Die sagt 2,60. Ich bin 2,60. Gehe weg und dann stehst du dahinter direkt. Und ich brauche da noch super lange, da fällt mir mein Popponel hin, alle Karten fahren raus. Dann sitze ich da noch und dann bestellst du nämlich einen Brezel. Sie sagt, 2,40, ich komme wieder hoch und sagt, womit habe ich gerade 2,60 gezahlt. Die sagt, rennt weg, wir rennen hinterher. Ja, aber auch wieder so direkt hintereinander, so dass ich direkt hinter dir klebe. Dass sie dich nicht sieht, aufs Grunde. Das haben wir geübt. Wir sind auch komplett von meiner Wohnung zum Hauptbahnhof gelaufen, dass ich so direkt hinter dir laufe, so dass man von vorne nur dich sehen kann. Wir so wirklich Körper an Körper, Rücken an Bauch. So Tandem-Walk. Einfach so direkt nacheinander laufen. Das müsste eigentlich ganz gut gehen, solange du kleine Schritte machst. Jaass uns uns weitere Hürden einbauen in diese eh schon schwierige Operation. Aber was ist, wenn wir ganz grosse Schuhe tragen, dass wir beide in denselben Schuhen stecken? Ja, wie gesagt, ist für mich der Fokus. Dass wir nur zwei Schuhe haben. Gibt es Tandemschuhe, wo zwei Füsse reinpassen, wo wir dann wirklich so unterwegs sind? Weil an den Füssen könnte man es ja hören. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Füsse sind, die dich verraten. Ich glaube, es ist dein Kleingeldstapel, der dich verrät. Sie lauft jedenfalls raus aus dem Hauptbahnhof. Wenn ich auch hoch in die Luft halte, da reflektiert sich die Sonne drin in den goldenen Münzen. Sie läuft aus dem Hauptbahnhof raus mit ihrem Becker-Outfit. Deswegen ist sie nicht so schnell. Wir holen sie ein, stellen sie, werfen nämlich unsere Brezeln, die wir vorhin gekauft haben, werfen die um die Füsse. Vorne hin, genau, vor sie, sie stolpert rüber, brr, fällt hin, kriecht dann noch so zurück auf dem Rücken und wir sind da vor und halten zwei Laugenstangen an den Hals. Ja, Laugenstangen an den Hals. Und ich werfe noch Salz in die Augen. Denk gar nicht dran. Denk gar nicht dran zu viel. Sie schaut so an ihre Hüfte, wo auch noch so eine Laugenstange steckt. Denk gar nicht dran. Ich nehme mir die Augen ab, ich nehme mir die Laugenstange an ihrer Hüfte ab, aus dem Holster. Und zerbreche sie in der Mitte und sie sagt, nein! Und wir halten ihr die Laugenstange ans Gesicht und sagen, so, jetzt haben wir die ganze Geschichte. Jetzt wollen wir die ganze Geschichte. Was meinen Sie denn, ich bin einfach nur eine Prinzlverkäuferin. Es hat sich ausgebacken. Ihr braucht einen coolen Spruch. Der Ofen ist aus, Lady. Der Ofen ist aus, Hexe. Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Der Ofen ist aus, Hexe. Aber das finde ich nicht schlecht. Hänsel und Gredel-Referenz, okay. Ja, okay, ich sag alles. Aber können wir vielleicht irgendwo hin, wo wir mehr Ruhe haben? Ja, okay, andere Setpiece. Als hier am Gleis. Am Gleis, am Gleis? Ich dachte, sie ist rausgelaufen. Okay. Sie ist rausgelaufen, in den Zug nach Madrid. Sie ist nach Madrid. Okay, dann. Das war die dümmste Verfolgungsjahr, der weiß, sie ist im Zug und er steht halt noch zehn Minuten.
Er steht noch zehn Minuten da und sie sitzt da und wir so ...
Okay, wir haben sie gestellt mit den Laugenstangen, sie erzählen die ganze Geschichte, aber jetzt und dann ...
Okay, kommt jetzt.
So ein dunkler Raum.
Back backstage.
Back backstage, ja.
Wir kommen zurück, stellen es, sitzen dann alle, okay, und jetzt die ganze Geschichte.
Währenddessen draußen
zwei Brezel bitte, zwei wichtig.
Jedes Mal stechender Schmerz, wenn sie das hört in ihrem Kopf.
Sprechen Sie!
Es hat sich ausge...
Das sagten sie bereits.
Die Lage ist gesalzen.
Wissen Sie?
Ich habe diesen Laden hier übernommen. Und wissen Sie, man macht ja nur mit den Brezeln wirklich Umsatz. Der ganze Rest ist ja nur Nonsens. Der Bio-Hänfling, der Kraftkorken, der Fitnessriegel, das ist doch alles nur, um die Leute hierher zu bringen. Man macht nur mit dem Brezeln Gewinn. Und wissen Sie, die Miete, Sie haben mir die Miete wieder erhöht. Wie oft in den letzten zwei Monaten? Dreimal haben Sie mir die Miete erhöht. Ja, das macht Sinn. Und ich musste die Brezeln erhöhen, obwohl ich es nicht wusste. Und dieser eine Bube kam mit seinem stechenden Blick und seinem gleißenden Kleingeldturm. Er kannte mein Geheimnis, er wusste alles. Was soll ich denn machen? Jede Woche diese Demütigung vor ihm. Ich konnte nicht anders, ich musste lügen. Und soll er sich doch freuen, verdammt, warum nimmt er denn nicht einfach die 20 Cent Rabatt an, warum macht er denn so einen Grabatz? Grabadabatz? Warum spricht er in seinem Podcast darüber? Ja, warum muss er denn in dieser einen Folge darüber sprechen? Und seitdem kamen alle und haben wollten nur 2,40 Euro zahlen dafür, weil die Vollidioten nicht verstehen, dass man vielleicht einfach nicht jeden Gag aus dem Podcast auch unbedingt in die eigene Welt übersetzen muss. Und die haben einfach keinen Anstand. Wait, jetzt bin ich... Langsam bin ich auf ihrer Seite. Ich sag Ihnen eins. Ich sag Ihnen einen Tipp. Oh Gott, dafür komme ich in Teufelsküche. In Teufelsbackstube? Ja. Ein bisschen mehr in Character.
Ja, tut mir leid.
Dafür werde ich paniert.
Auf Garstufe zwei.
Dafür werde ich mit Umluft gebacken.
Entschuldigung.
Ich muss kurz an die frische Umluft.
Reden Sie mit Doktor Brock. Jetzt habe ich es gesagt. Doktor Brock? Reden Sie mit Doktor Brock. Doktor Brock. Aber das haben Sie nicht von mir. Wer ist Doktor Brock? Das haben Sie aber nicht von mir. Wie finden wir Doktor Brock? Und dann macht sie so, nimmt sie Mehl, schmeißt Mehl auf den Boden und verschwindet rein dieser Mehlstaubwolk.
Um Doktor Brock zu finden, folgen sie den Brotkrümeln.
Sie zeigt sie auf ihrer Backstube, wo aus dem Ofen so kleine Krümel herausfinden, die Hintertür hinaus.
Die Ermittler drehen sich um und plötzlich Mehl-Explosion. Sie und wir werden auch die Tür ins Schloss fallen. Und wie es weitergeht mit der spannenden Suche nach Doktor Brock, erfahrt ihr nächste Woche. Wenn es weitergeht in unserem Hörspielabenteuer Salz und 2,40 Euro. Die gesalzene Geschichte des vielleicht grössten Brezeldiebstahls allerzeit. 2,40 Euro. Ja, ich bin wahnsinnig begeistert. Und ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt machen soll. Soll ich dann wieder hingehen und es ist jede Woche peinlich? Es gibt ja eine Peinlichkeitstoleranz. Und bei mir ist die einfach niedrig, wenn ich gerade aufgestanden bin. Ich wache auf, will meine Frühstücksbrezeln, gehe zum Hauptbahnhof und dann immer diese peinliche Situation. Abends könnte ich das ertragen, aber morgens nicht. Wir müssen uns das auch im Graph vorstellen. Also Y-Achse wäre Lebensqualität, die sich entweder durch soziale, nette, soziale Interaktionen, beziehungsweise nicht negative soziale Interaktionen und Geschmack... Geh auch bis jetzt schon zu. Konzentrier dich, konzentrier dich. Also Y-Achse Lebensqualität, X-Achse Zeit. Okay. So, im Laufe der Zeit wurde die Lebensqualität bei diesem Becker A immer A1. Der andere heißt A2. Ich mache es noch ein bisschen komplizierter, aus Spaß. Okay. Also Becker A1. Zum Glück keine griechischen Zahlen, griechischen Vorstammen. Okay, Omega 1. Nein, wie schreibt man das? Wo ist das auf der Tastatur? Also, Becker Omega-1. Beta-1. Beta-1. Beta-1. Beta-1. Wurde immer unangenehmer. Lebenspolitik sank. Aber die besten Brätsel. Das heißt, es steigt von ganz oben links oben über die Zeit nach ganz unten rechts. Jetzt die Frage, wann sind die Brätsel Beta-2 vielleicht sogar besser als ... Du brauchst ja Lebensqualität, Qualität der Brezel, Zeit. Eigentlich brauchst du Zeit überhaupt nicht. Du brauchst nur Lebensqualität und Qualität der Brezel. Bist du welcher Qualität der Brezel bereit, das in Kauf zu nehmen? Super, Zeit brauchen wir nicht. Je besser die Je brezel, desto niedriger die Lebensqualität und Qualität der Brezel. Bist du welcher Qualität der Brezel bist du bereit, das in Kauf zu nehmen? Super, Zeit brauchen wir nicht. Je besser die Brezel, desto niedriger die Lebensqualität. Ja, aber jetzt die Frage. Willst du eine gute Brezel mit Peinlichkeit oder willst du eine schwache Brezel mit angenehmer sozialer Interaktion? Weswegen ich die Zeit wollte, ist ja, dass du irgendwann einen Schnittpunkt hast, wo die Lebensqualität fast besser ist bei Bäcker Nummer zwei, Beta zwei oder Beta drei. Aber warum verändert sich die Situation denn mit der Zeit? Naja, durch die soziale Blödigkeit von allen Beteiligten in dieser... Vieh ist das, oder was? Naja, ich glaube, also irgendwann gibt es... Ich will einfach einen Schnittpunkt erzeugen, wo irgendwann Beta zwei über... Ja, ich glaube, ich nähern mich diesem Schnittpunkt, weil es ist einfach unangenehm. Und man stellt sich vor, die Briten werden weiter ... Also, habe ich jetzt einen Rabatt von 20 Cent oder kriege ich immer 2,40 Euro? Was ist, wenn die nächste Preiserhöhung kommt? Die wird ja kommen. Nee, ich glaube, die wird nicht mehr kommen. Doch, die wird kommen. Du hast sie entlarvt. Die wird kommen. Du hast sie gesteht und entlarvt. Meinst du, ich habe das gestoppt für immer? Nein. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Aber jetzt ist es eher ... Also, sie haben esbertrieben, und das wurde Ihnen jetzt aufgezeigt. Und jetzt, glaube ich, müssen Sie sich entweder im normalen Zyklus die Preise erhöhen oder, keine Ahnung, Sie lassen sich jetzt ein bisschen Zeit um zu kompensieren. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Sie jetzt im nächsten Schritt die Preise wieder erhöhen werden, weil das geht ja nicht. Du hast Ihnen aufgezeigt, dass Sie zu gierig waren. Ich sag mal so, an alle Brezelbäcker am Kölner Hauptbahnhof, ihr habt die minderwertigen Brezel. Schreibt mit kurz. Ich wäre bereit, meine Stammbäckerei zu wechseln, wenn ihr Bedingung eine Tüte habt, die nicht knistert. Moment, okay, jetzt kommt er bei der Graph, ich weiß. Weil auch wenn diese besagte Bäckerei die besten Brezeln hat, hat sie auch die lauteste Tüte. Lautstärke Dezibel durch Tüte hoch. Sodass, wenn ich im Zug sitze, ich einfach den gesamten Abteil unterhalte und ihr wisst, was ich am meisten hasse im Leben, ist laut zu sein im Ruheabteil, gilt vor allem für mich. Das heisst, ich sitze da wirklich mit feinen Hummerhänden, versuche da die Brezeln aus der Tüte zu schälen, die lächerlich laut ist. Also diese Tüte ist lächerlich, das könnte ein Instrument sein. Also das ist was so dieses Backpapier, also dieses ganz steife Papier, was einfach so wirklich bricht und kracht. Das ist wie wenn du so ein Schiff durch so Eisscheulen durchfährst, wenn du da reinkracht. Vielleicht ist die gut für die, vielleicht ist die auch recycelte Material und jetzt ist die besser. Da kommt noch der Umweltaspekt in den Graphen hinein. Der interessiert mich nicht. Liebe Bäcker, ich wäre bereit, meine Stammbäckerei zu ändern, wenn mir jemand eine weniger knisternde Tüte vorlegt, auch, und da bin ich bereit, den Kompromiss einzugehen, auch bei weiterhin minderwertiger Brezelqualität. Das ist mein Angebot. Das heißt, die Lautstärke der Tüte ist ja fast wichtiger als die Brezelqualität. Ich glaube einfach, dass wir bei der Brezelqualität nicht weiterkommen. Man muss ja auch realistische Standards setzen. Aber erzähl doch mal, was sich an den anderen Brezeln stört. Die sind so weich. Moment, du magst harte Brezel? Ich liebe weiche Brezel. Manche sind auch zu hart und manche sind auch zu feich. Und nur die sind genau richtig. Und die haben diese dunkle Lauge-Färbung. Es gibt ja dann so diese hellorange... Nee, nee, nee, nee. Also es gibt ja erst mal zwei unterschiedliche Arten von Brezeln. Da müssen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Wollen wir nicht drüber reden. Es gibt ja die, die unten so aufgerissen sind und die, die unten geschlossen sind. Die, die unten geschlossen sind, findest du ja kaum. Das sind, glaube ich, die Original-Bayerische. Ich dachte immer, die waren zu kurz drin. Nein, nein, nein, nein, das sind völlig unterschiedliche Anfragen. Oder Brezeln oder Brezen, ist ja jetzt auch egal. Und deswegen... Sprich es halt nicht an! Ich mag es, wenn die eher dunkler sind. Das sind so diese ganz hellen, ich meine, du hast vorhin D angesprochen. Ich bitte dich. Ja. Also, naja, teilweise haben die Butter mit drin. Teilweise wurde da so, und das habe ich auch mal irgendwo mal gegessen, da war so ein kleiner, wie man es in Schokokroissons kennt, oder so, oder Pins au Chocolat, hast ja so kleine Stangen Schoko drin. Und da war wie so eine Stange Butter, war im Rand unten drin. Oh. Oh, Butterbrezel. Und manchmal haben die bei D Butterbrezel. Ja, Butterbrezel ist natürlich immer eine ganz andere Hausnummer. Da müssen wir immer ganz anders denken, weil da brauchst du ganz andere Eigenschaften für die Brezel. Aber das ist auch ein anderes Thema. Weil ich kann es mir nicht leisten, jede Woche zwei Butterbrezel in mir reinzuschnabulieren. Das geht nicht so. Das ist der Morgen, da brauchst du einfach mal ein bisschen eine Basis. Und deswegen mag ich es wenn die dunkel sind. Nein, also wie gesagt, ich halte die Augen offen beim Hamburger Hauptbahnhof. Ihr könnt mir gerne euer Angebot unterbreiten. Ich bin auf der Suche, Köln, Entschuldigung, ich bin auf der Suche, Hamburg kriegst ja weit und weit keine Brezeln. Aber ich bin bereit, mir euer Angebot anzuhören. Es wird langsam so Joe Rogan-mäßig, es wird in alle Richtungen geschossen, aber bei uns hat es halt keinen Skandalwert, weil du halt gegen die Brezelaufkommen am Hauptburger Ham, das ist so die Skandalträchtigkeit, der Aussagen, die jetzt hier kommen. Der Aufschrei wird, glaube ich, sehr gering sein. Da gibt es halt ein gutes Franzbrötchen, da müssen wir dann nochmal ein komplett anderes Kapitel aufmachen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Da hast du eine andere Geschichte erlebt, aber die gehört jetzt hier nicht hin. Das ist der völlig falsche Ort. Das wäre jetzt völlig unpassend, diese Franzbrötchen-Geschichte jetzt erzählen. Das wäre völlig albern. Ja, finde ich interessant. Ich würde dem Ganzen gerne auf die Geschichte kommen. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde Detektiv Thais nicht die schlechteste in unserem Ensemble. Sie ist ja noch mit ihrem alten Fall, dem Dominos-Trinkgeld-geldskandal beschäftigt, da hat sie sich ja richtig reingegraben gerade und da ist sie hier komplett vereinnahmt, also die wird gerade keine Zeit haben für weitere Aufträge. Stimmt, wir hatten herausgefunden, dass die bei Dominos das Trinkgeld nicht bekommen. Genau, wenn du online bestellst und online ein Trinkgeld abgebucht bekommst, kriegen die Fahrer das nicht. War der Vorwurf zumindest.
Also diese ganzen Finanzskandale, die wir hier aufdecken. Wir sind Finanz-Tais, die die großen Finanzskandale aufdeckt in der Lebensmittelindustrie. Aber eine Sache möchte ich ganz kurz sagen, weil ich glaube, ich habe jetzt gerade die Aufmerksamkeit von vielen Bäckern. Und zwar, es gibt ja dieses alte Problem, du bestellst, sagen wir mal, ein Cremehörnchen und eine Brezel. So, und jetzt gibt es immer diese Frage, kann die in eine Tüte?
Und ich denke mir, sobald... dieses alte Problem, du bestellst, sagen wir mal, ein Cremehörnchen und eine Brezel. So, und jetzt gibt es immer diese Frage, kann die in eine Tüte?
Und ich denke mir, sobald Salz im Spiel ist, hat Süssgebäck nichts in der Tüte mehr zu suchen.
Sie wollen nur Tüten sparen. Dass du diesen Umweltaspekt komplett ausklammest bei deinem Bäckergang, ist okay, mach halt.
Aber ich sage immer, eine Tüte passt mir, passt mir nein, nein. Mir geht es darum, was ist der Default? Was ist der Default? Du kannst ja fragen, geht es in eine Tüte? Dann sagst du vielleicht halt nein. Aber das Problem ist, dass bei vielen Bäckern eine Tüte Default ist und du extra sagen musst, du kannst dich zwei separate Tüte. Und das ist Bullshit. Ich finde, der Default sollte sein, sobald Salz im Spiel ist. Wir reden nicht, also angenommen, du holst dir ein Zimt-Wuppi und irgendwie ein Kaiserbrötchen, ja, kein Salz außen dran, zusammen in einer Tüte, kein Problem.
Aber inzwischen...
Sobald diese Salzlaugensachen mit dabei ist, die einfach direkt alles Süße ansalzen, keine Chance.
Inzwischen zweifle ich ein bisschen an deinem Auftritt bei Bäckern.
Wenn du da ankommst mit der kleine, schüchterne Junge, der sagt, zwei Brezel bitte, bitte, Entschuldigung, zwei Brezel bitte, Laugenbrezel bitte, wo nichts mehr organisch klingt, sondern nur noch auswendig gelernt, falsch vortragen. Ich glaube, was ich gerade bei der Tütensache merke, du hast so eine Mit-mir-kann-man-alles-machen-Kappe aufgefühlt. Ja, das kann man. So, und die spielen einfach, die machen Dynamic Pricing, die versuchen es. Die spielen mit mir. Genau. Und jetzt wird nämlich, jetzt kommt der große Plottwist, die Drachenfrau, die Hexe, die alles, den ganzen Plot geschmiedet hat, ist eigentlich nur ist so diese Snape-Figur, wo am Ende rauskommt, sie war auf der Seite. Wir wissen nicht, wie es mit Dr. Brock weitergeht. Am Ende sagt sie nämlich zu dir, du hast die Augen deiner Mutter und stirbst dann an der Laugenstange in ihrem Herzen. Und sie hat die ganze Zeit, sie musste die ganze Zeit, sie mussten die Preise erhöhen, das wäre der Laden bankrott gegangen, aber sie hat gesagt, nein, 2,40. Weil sie so diese Beziehung hat, für dich nur 2,40, Florentin. Und dann stirbt sie so. Wieso hat sie meinen Namen? Stimmt, sie wusste, wer ich bin. Genau. Dein Vater hat auch immer mit dem Kleingeldstapel gezahlt. Ihr Herz explodiert? Ja, und dann sagt, ja. Und dann in dem Denkarium und Dumbledore fragt, die ganze Zeit über die ganze Zeit war sie noch mit dem Vater.
Toll.
Wo alle mit den Laugenstangen rumwedeln. Harry Potter und die Laugenstange.
Irgendwie gefallen mir diese neuen
Harry Potter Filme nicht mehr so gut.
Es gibt vier Häuser.
Laugen,
Süsskram,
Baguette und
die französische Schule Baguette.
Ne, das ist Croissant.
Le Cro-Bac. Oh, die Mädchenschule Cro-Bac. Und da sage ich aber wirklich, wie wenig Respekt kann man als Bäcker denn vor seinem Backwerk haben, dass du in dieselbe Tüte eine Laugenbrezel mit Salzalarm steckst und irgendwie ein Wuppi oder sowas. Also das ist albern, das geht nicht. Da bitte auch an alle Bäckerei-Fachkräft-Verkäufer einfach aufpassen. Nicht alles in dieselbe Tüte zusammenwerfen. Weil ich finde es auch lustig, ich gehe häufig zu einem Kiosk, wo immer alles andere Preise hat, aber wo auch kein System erkennbar ist. Und ich aber auch immer bereit bin, die Preise zu zahlen, weil ich auch Angst habe vor sozialen Interaktionen. weil ich sage doch nicht, was er letzte Woche nur einen Euro gekostet. Das ist so ein Dynamic Pricing Kiosk. Ein bisschen habe ich es auch beobachtet bei Amazon, weil ich habe mir jetzt zum ersten Mal eine elektronische Zahnbürste gekauft. Wow, da wird jemand erwachsen langsam. Da wird jemand wirklich erwachsen. Ich habe mir eine ältere Teilmisse gekauft und dann kann man die bei Amazon kaufen. Und Und die heißt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, Produkthersteller Serie 7. Und es gibt verschiedene Serien, Serie 5, 6, 7. Und ich wollte halt dann, wenn ich das einmal dafür Geld ausgebe, dann Serie 7 haben, die krasseste. Alle Namen geändert. So, hab dann geguckt 7 eingeguckt, Produkthersteller eingegeben und dann hat Amazon mir fünf verschiedene Serie 7 Modelle gegeben. Und alle waren unterschiedlich teurer. Von 150 Euro, nee, von 120 Euro bis 250 Euro war diese Preisspanne. Da bin ich auf produkthersteller.de gegangen,
von dem Produkthersteller, und habe gesehen, es gibt nur ein Modell von Serie 7. Es gibt nur ein Serie 7 Modell. Serie 7 ist quasi dieses eine Modell. Die haben verschiedene Dinge,
die verschiedene Sachen können, und Serie 7 kann halt das, dann gibt es auch Serie 8 vielleicht,
aber es gibt nur ein Modell. Und dann bin ich draufgegangen jeweils und wollte dann die Artikelnummern vergleichen und die Seriennummern vergleichen, wurden nicht angeschrieben, nur bei einer stand die Seriennummer. Es standen unterschiedliche Daten drin, ab April 2021 im Sortiment und so, hab alles verglichen, war ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Aber es waren die... Wir rufen uns Thais an, jetzt reicht's, jetzt reicht's wirklich, also wir brauchen, wir müssen unseren Investigativ-Bluthund loslassen, weil da passieren zu viele schlimme Dinge. Ja, und dann habe ich halt die billigste genommen und es kam halt das an, was es gibt, es gibt nämlich nur ein Produkt und das fand ich total faszinierend, es ist wie der Kiosk, Amazon ist genau wie der Kiosk nebenan bei mir, wo ich sag, hier, wo ich einen Snickers-Riegel hinlege und es kostet mal 90 Cent und mal 2,60 Euro. Wahnsinn. Und man sieht es immer an dem Verkäufer, der immer überlegt, wenn er einen Preis sagt. So als müsste er in seine Schachspieler, die so ihre Eröffnungsdatenbank durchgehen und alles auswendig gelernt haben. Und er geht kurz in seinen Gedächtnispalast und sagt mir, was ein Snickers kostet. Nein, er weiß es nicht. Er improvisiert und hofft, dass ich mitgehe. Ja, das ist immer so ein Wert, der würfelt das aus. Das ist immer so ein Euro plus zwei wie sechs einfach so. Irgendwie nochmal so was Willkürliches umdraubt. Ja, oder es ist halt wie so flights.google.com, die halt auch gucken, von welchem Browser bist du gerade am Start. Wie teuer sind die Erdnüsse gerade? Er hat die Website offen, Preis von aktuellen Erdnüssen, wie viel ist das Snickers gerade? Das stimmt schon. Nee, aber die checken ja, dass du mit
Safari online gehst. Ach so.
Und dann checken die, ah, okay, der hat
wohl schon ein MacBook, der hat Geld, da ist was
zu holen. Safari teurer als
Mozilla zum Beispiel.
Und das ist... Moment, willst du mir sagen,
dass die Bäckereifachverkäuferin denkt,
ich hab nicht viel Geld? Du bist ein armer Schlucker.
Sie dachte immer, du hast Geld,
deswegen wurden die Preise ständig erhöht, weil du dich immer besser angezogen hast. Stimmt, ich habe mich in der Zeit tatsächlich immer besser angezogen. Irgendwann hatte ich so eine Weste an, dann hatte ich so einen Hut, so einen Gehstock. Und dann plötzlich bist du wieder mit deiner Jonghose gekommen, sie hat gemeint, das war der gleiche Typ all along. Jetzt war ich jetzt Wahnsinn. Darf man einfach den Preis bestimmen, wie man will, oder gibt es eine Regel? Eben nicht, Dynamic Pricing ist verb ist verboten. Von wem? Der Fiskus. Ja, Stefan, du sagst das immer, der Fiskus, aber was genau meinst du damit Fiskus? Was ist das für ein Wort? Das Finanzsystem. Der Fiskus. Das globale Finanzsystem. Und also, wer taucht bei meinem Laden auf, wenn ich dieses Dynamic Pricing mache? Herr Fiskus. Oder einfach nur Fiskus, das ist einfach ein Typ. Nee, ist ein Tierwesen, so ein Hummer, halb Hummer, halb Fuchs, der Fiskus. Ja, eigentlich für, welches Tier steht für Geld? Eigentlich schon so Eichhörnchen, die das sammeln in den Backen oder so und dann so vergraben und so ein Tresor haben mit ganz viel oder Bienen. Die reichsten Tiere der Welt, Bienen. Ja, stimmt schon. Welches Tier, gibt es das reichste Tier der Welt? Es gibt eine Liste der reichsten Menschen der Welt. Was ist das reichste Tier der Welt? Ja, das ist ein Reichtum. Du kannst ja Honig einfach auch einen Wert geben. Das heißt, so ein Bienenstock hat einfach fünf Liter Honig. Ja, aber das ist jetzt ein Wert, der den Bienen sehr entgegenkommt und dem Fisch nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Wenn der Honigwert, das ist die Reichweite der Weltbestimmung, sagen die Fische, sagen diese schönen, gekeilten Fische diese tollen, mit diesen tollen Gewändern an oder diese dievenhaften Seepferdchen sagen dann, Entschuldigung. Ja, aber die haben ja nichts. Aber wenn so ein Eichhörnchen, das irgendwie so hundert Gramm Erdnüsse gesammelt hat, kannst ja sagen, Öltier hier kostet so und so viel und dann kannst du dem Eichhörnchen Vermögen zurechnen.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Eines kommt der Fiskus vorbei, ist eine fabelhafte Gestalt und sagt, aha, so nicht.
Letztes Woche habe ich noch 1,60 Euro gezahlt für meinen Schokopudding und heute mehr. Kommen Sie mit, kommen Sie mit, ich bringe Sie in den Fiskus-Palast. Das ist dann so Frozen-mäßig, stell dir mir vor. Ja, so ein riesiger Palast. Und du gehst in irgendeine Sparkassenfiliale und drückst da so, machst so eine geheime Kombination auf dem Bankautomaten, so 9,9,5-9, dreht sich das um, so ein Gang, einfach so eine alte Treppe und dann nimmt er so eine Fackel aus dem Halter und dann so, folgen Sie mir!
Und er hat auch so ganz hohe Absätze und klappert dann so diese Treppe runter.
Ich gehe ihm dann daher. Wo gehen wir denn hin, Herr Fiskus?
Wir fahren jetzt auf dem Dutton Highway.
Okay, merkwürdig.
Und dann ist man in der Untergrundbahn so, wuuu, so ganz schnell so Sitze vorbeirauscht, so ein grosses Laufband.
Und dann muss man, ah, sie müssen in den richtigen Moment abpassen.
Drei, zwei, eins, Sprung.
Und dann muss man in dem richtigen Moment auf dieses Laufband springen.
Wie so eine Unter- so eine Mienbahn. Fährt man dann weg. Und du schaust auf das Namensstil von diesem Fiskus und schaust an, was steht da. Da steht Doktor Brock. Buh,et unser kleiner Film. Vielen Dank für alle, die mitgemacht haben, vielen Dank für alle, die die Story geschrieben haben, vielen Dank an die Autoren und Autorinnen. Vielen Dank an euch als Marktforschungsteam. Lasst eure Feedback gerne jetzt auf diesem gelben Zettel hier stehen, was ihr von dem Film heilt. Wenn ihr wollt, dass wir es häufiger machen, uns Geschichten drei Jahre lang ausdenken und dann performen, sagt einfach Bescheid. In der Rolle des Viscos! Florentin Will! Dankeschön, vielen Dank! Vielen Dank, Dankeschön! In der Rolle der Brezel-Verkäuferin Stefan Tietze! Vielen Dank, Dankeschön! In der Rolle des 240er- Rolle des 240er haben wir Florian Will. Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Und natürlich als Autor der ganzen Geschichten, Aaron Sorkin. Das hat man gemerkt an den Dialogen. Aber schwache Action. Also diese ICE-Verfolgungsjagd war schwach, aber der Rest war glücklich. War scheisse, fand ich. Richtig scheisse. Harte Meinung. Gut, habt ihr sowas auch gemacht, Marktforschung für eure Serie? Und dann haben die Leute gesagt, das habe ich nicht verstanden. Und dann sagt man, ja, weil du dumm bist. Weil wir Trottel haben. Nee, weiß ich gar nicht. Glaub schon. Also nicht ich. Ich saß jetzt nicht irgendwo hinter so einer verspiegelten Glaswand, wo ich die nicht gesehen habe, weil die Leute mich alle gesehen haben, sondern das ist nicht passiert, das war nie. Ich saß nie. Stefan, setz dich mal hierhin und so ein ganzer Marktforschungsraum sieht dich. Aber ich gucke in den Spiegel. Das ist nie passiert. Ich habe mich nie in den falschen Raum gesetzt. Das ist doch ein Sketch, oder?
Es gibt auch viele Sketche so mit Marktforschungsgruppen, und man macht einfach der ganze Gag, der der Sketches ist, der Spiegel wurde falsch rum installiert. Ja. Die Leute sehen das Team, die sich Notizen machen, und die sehen sich immer nur selber. Die sehen sich immer nur selber. Das ist fantastisch. Das ist aber nie passiert, dass ich mich in den falschen Raum gesetzt habe. Okay. Okay, gut gab dann höchstens zum Trailer und sowas, zum Marketinggedöns gab sowas. Aber jetzt nicht Story. Also uns wurde nie gesagt, Leute, dass alle Leute hassen Figur. Schreibt diese Krebswesen wieder raus, die kommen nicht an. Schreibt raus, dass die Patronus beschweren. Das gab es jetzt nicht, selten gab es das.
Gut, freut mich, ist ja gut.
Wir sind alle gespannt,
was als nächstes kommt. Ja, ich auch.
Aber ich habe auch gemerkt,
arbeiten, ja, ist
nervig.
Lieber nix machen, oder? Lieber nix, gar nix
machen. Gar nix machen. Und ab und zu
ein Brezel kaufen am Kölner Hauptbahnhof.
Ich halte euch auf dem Laufenden, wie es
weitergeht. Ansonsten bitte nervt die nicht.
Wir hören uns hier mit dem
grossen Update nächste Woche wieder. Bis
dahin. Thais, melde dich, wie weit du bist.
Wir haben einige Aufträge für dich, ansonsten
haut rein, wir heben ab bis nächste Woche. Mach's gut, ciao!
Ab eine schöne Woche, mach's gut! It's the worst Burr-Production.